Ian's 33 we were in our like mid to late
20s YouTube was the wild west and we
were all funny guys being crazy and edgy
and stuff and you know it only makes
sense that we're all now at a certain
point where we're like you know time to
grow up a little bit so I I'm very
opposed to this obscenely toxic notion
that change is weakness growth is
weakness people think that if I I will
never change because I'm so authentic
it's like no you're just a coward
somehow growing or changing your mind it
means that you are a liar means that
you're a hypocrite and again I think I
don't know who said this maybe Mark
Twain a hypocrite is sometimes just a
man who's uh changing
foreign
[Music]